the coin of aries second of his name
had landed on madness but half the coins
of the targaryens had landed so
yet only ares would be known as the mad
king thanks in no small part to the
defiance of duskendale
duskendale was the greatest port on
blackwater bay until aegon built king's
landing
as the capital grew richer and more
prosperous
it sucked ships and gold away from
duskendale
to halt its long decline the lord of
sir dennis darklin petitioned king aerys
for a royal charter that would allow him
to levy his own port fees and taxes
which would obviously be lower than
in king's landing the hand of the king
tywin lannister refused but
knowing of the tension between the hand
and its king sir dennis invited the king
to duskendale to evaluate his petition
himself
rather than deferring to his hand when
tywin admonished the king to refuse
as any sensible adviser would a petulant
and bristling air is instead accepted
traveling to duskendale with a small
retinue and only one of his kingsguard
as soon as aerys stepped within the city
sir dennis seized him killing the
kingsguard and the few others who dared
to defend their king
aerys was hauled to the dungeons to have
his beard pulled
and have other petty cruelties inflicted
on his royal person
lord tywin immediately raised an army
and marched on duskendale
but the dennis threatened to kill the
king at the first signs of an assault
if sir dennis hoped to force tywin to
offer terms he didn't know lord tywin
who refused to even parley until sir
dennis released the king and surrendered
the royal army surrounded the city and
the royal navy blockaded it
so dennis had clearly not anticipated
such
obstinacy nor that the king's hand would
be in no rush to save the maddening king
when as lord tywin himself pointed out
the realm had a better option in the
king's much
more stable son prince rhaegar after six
months
lord tywin's patience was at an end
or at least none could claim he acted
recklessly if he now stormed the city
and sir dennis killed the king
but the dutiful and honorable sir
barristan the bold volunteered to
infiltrate the city and rescue his king
single-handedly
as befit his kingsguard oath tywin
couldn't
refuse such valor publicly
and so begrudge sir barristan one night
then he would storm the city and put
every man woman
and child to the sword with only his
hands
sir barristan climbed the city walls in
the dark of night
and snuck through the city disguised as
a beggar evading patrols and suspicious
townspeople
when he reached the walls of the city
keith the dunn forward
he scaled those by hand as well even
dispatching the wall guard before he
could sound an alarm
with incredible bravery and luck sir
barristan made his way to the dungeons
and
freed his king then sir barristan's luck
ran out
the cry went up through the castle
someone had discovered the king was gone
with horns and trumpets blaring an alarm
sir barristan
cut their way to the stables avenging
his slain
guard brother but taking an arrow to his
chest
slipping through the castle gate just as
it closed
the wounded sir barristan and aries rode
through the rails town
racing for the city walls and beyond it
the safety of the royal army
lord tywin's archers raced forward to
clear the walls of defenders
and sir barristan the bold earned
immortality by delivering king aerys to
the waiting if not
welcoming arms off his hand
without his hostage sir dennis
surrendered and
begged mercy from the same king he'd
imprisoned
most men would have had none ares had
less
he commanded sir dennis to be executed
along with any man woman or
child who bore his family name and
anyone who once had
as for sir dennis's foreign wife who had
urged his defiance
aries commanded that her tongue and
womanly parts
be torn out and she be burned alive
it was his first time passing such a
sentence
it must have given him a taste for it
for the king rescued from duskendale was
not the same king who'd entered it
many men would crack after six months in
a dark cell being
mocked prodded and tweaked aerys had
arrived cracked
now he was shattered for years he would
refuse to leave the red keep
encouraged now died by his worried
advisors since he also refused to allow
any blades near his person
even to shave his beard cut his hair and
trim his nails
he began to see enemies in every shadow
who vanished
only when the fires burned
aerys targaryen was the last of his name
to sit on the iron throne
known far and wide as the mad king
his was a reign of instability and
terror
the seven kingdoms are well rid of him
and his kind
oh he may have appeared to be a capable
ruler at first
but that was due in no small part to his
counselors led by the hand of the king
tywin lannister there may have been
years of peace and prosperity
during aerys reign but it was tywin who
was really running the country
as eris spiraled further and further
into insanity
the dragons spawn were famous for losing
their minds
it was the price they paid for centuries
of keeping the bloodlines pure
and eris more than happily continued the
noble
sister tradition of his forefathers
as the years passed erys's behavior
became increasingly erratic
he cut himself so often on his iron
throne many referred to him as
king scab though never to his face
it was rumored he had developed an
obsession with wildfire
and was known to inflict horrific
punishments on those he considered
enemies
including burning them alive as his
paranoia and bloodlust grew he had a
bitter falling out with lord tywin
who had served the crown faithfully for
20 years
at least tywin was able to leave the job
with his life and fortunes intact
subsequent hands of king aerys weren't
so fortunate
then the targaryens went too far
the crown prince rhaegar abducted lyanna
stark
daughter of rickard stark the lord of
winterfell
she was my betrothed she was my beloved
beautiful and spirited woman and i loved
her more than life itself
rhaegar went south with lyanna hiding
her away in dawn
what harm he inflicted on the poor girl
the gods only know
brandon stark lyanna's eldest brother
was outraged
he rode to king's landing to confront
the king
and demand his sister's safe return
instead aerys had him executed his
father
rickard stark as well there wasn't much
left to discuss after that
heiress feared their loved ones would
seek revenge for what he did
he was right to be afraid
heiress wasted no time in calling for
the heads of brandon's younger brother
my friend eddard stark and my head
too of course i'm sorry he didn't come
looking for it himself
alongside john aaron of the vale the man
who fostered ned and i
as children baratheons starks and
tully's all
called their banners once our rebellion
began
the mad king's days were numbered
as word of king harry's erratic and
troubling behavior
spread throughout the seven kingdoms
lord rickard stark
continued to serve his king faithfully
as warden of the north
the proud father of four children his
daughter lyanna
was engaged to robert baratheon the
young lord of storm's end
centuries of peace between the north and
the iron throne
ended the day rhaegar targaryen prince
of dragonstone
abducted lyanna enraged
brandon stark rode to king's landing
demanding the release of his sister
and the death of rhaegar aries
arrested him for treason and called his
father
to come to the capitol to ransom him
when lord rickard complied ayer is now
utterly mad
arrested him for treason as well
lord rickard demanded a trial by combat
aries declared fire the champion of
house targaryen
and had lord rickard suspended from the
rafters of the throne room
while pyromancers lit a blaze beneath
him
as he burned brandon was brought into
the throne room
a leather cord attached to a
strangulation device was wrapped around
his neck
aries told brandon his father was a dead
man
but there was a chance to save him a
long sword was placed on the floor just
out of brandon's reach
and the more he struggled to reach it
the more the cord
tightened around his throat brandon
stark
strangled himself trying to free his
father
who was roasted alive in his own armor
the entire court stood and watched this
atrocity take place
so jamie lannister and the kingsguard
among them
the mad king was reported to have
laughed hysterically
as these two noble men were tortured and
brutally killed before him
seeking to rid the world of all his
supposed enemies
heiress called for the head of rickard's
younger son eddard stark
and lyanna's betrothed robert baratheon
he sent word to lord john erin who'd
fostered both young men and the eerie to
apprehend them
instead lord aaron joined houses stark
and baratheon
in rebellion robert vowed to kill
rhaegar targaryen and get his belovedly
honor back
as aries targaryen's behavior grew more
and more erratic
the task of ruling the seven kingdoms
fell to me
timing lannister i had served aries for
nearly 20 years
and as a result the realm had prospered
the royal coffers were full
the land was at peace
but aries grew increasingly hostile
jealous of the success many credited to
me
my power and influence unnerved him
the captain of my personal guard sir
ellen payne was once overheard making
offhand
comments regarding who was the true
ruler of westeros
when the king was given this information
he had elim payne's tongue
ripped out with hot pincers
it was my desire to unite the houses of
lannister and targaryen
through marriage my daughter cersei
would marry aries eldest son
prince rhaegar such a union made perfect
sense for all parties
however aries senses had begun to leave
him
quite some time earlier instead of
uniting the royal family with its most
loyal and powerful ally ares chose
instead to insult
my family that such a match was
beneath rhaegar instead he chose elia
martell
of dawn to be rhaegar's wife
as if to rub salt in my wounds ares
appointed
jaime my son to the king's guard
the king's guard may be an honor for
lesser families than ours
but it is a lifetime appointment that
forces him to renounce
all family holdings
this creates a difficulty in naming an
heir to casterly rock
but ares knew all that
i had grown tired of the king's constant
provocation
thus i resigned my post as aries hand
and returned to casterly rock with my
considerable forces
when robert baratheon rebelled against
the throne
aries grew fearful that i would join
with robert's forces and rise against
him
he thought himself clever and kept jamie
very close
as if warning me he sunk deeper and
deeper into delusion
paranoia and violence i've heard it said
he became obsessed with wildfire
a substance which once lit cannot be
extinguished
convinced he had enemies all around him
he wouldn't allow blades in his presence
save for those of his king's guard
alas that proved to be his undoing